[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: The next
speaker is Hans Beta,
who's known in the
physics community
as a person who knows
everything, and has
done almost everything.
I remember when I first--
no, no, that's wrong--
I remember at the
early Rochester
meetings on high energy physics,
whenever there was a question--
"Has this experiment been done?"
"Has this calculation
been done?"
"What is the result of this?"
"What is known about this?"--
automatically, every head
turned to Professor Beta.
And his answer was awaited,
and furthermore believed.
And he always answered, too.
There probably is no field of
physics to which he has not
made an important contribution.
He received a
Nobel Prize in 1967
for the discovery
of the carbon cycle
as a source of energy
generation in the sun.
Professor Beta was
born in Germany,
came to the United States
as a refugee from the Nazis.
He arrived at Cornell in
1935, and more or less has
been there ever since, with
the exception, of course,
of the years of the
Second World War,
where he worked here for a
while, and then in Los Alamos,
where he was central
in the construction
of the first nuclear weapons.
He was the leader of the
theoretical group there.
Ever since, while conducting--
while engaging actively
in physics research
and teaching,
he has worked rationally
and effectively
to exploit and to understand
and to contain the nuclear fire
which he helped to invent.
He was my thesis
advisor 38 years ago.
It was hard.
[LAUGHTER]
But I learned a
lot and survived.
So it's a real pleasure
to welcome him back
to MIT, Professor Beta.
His title today is
Solar Neutrinos.
[APPLAUSE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PRESENTER: Yes, okay, let
me show you how that works.
Say something.
BETA: Okay.
PRESENTER: I think so.
Let me show you how this works,
so you can turn it on and off.
BETA: I think I'm
following that.
PRESENTER: Are you
going to use the--
BETA: Yes.
PRESENTER: Okay.
It turns on by pushing
the lever at the bottom.
BETA: Oh, it's practically in--
[? Friesis, ?] thanks
for the welcome.
I want to correct your
introduction by one point.
I have never worked on general
relativity, and I don't--
[LAUGHTER]
--don't intend to do so.
I'm happy to be here to
join in congratulations to
[? Filmores. ?] But it is
also a sad occasion for me.
I'm quite used to getting
old, but it is very depressing
if young people get old, also.
[LAUGHTER]
When I met Phil, he was
28, and a very young man.
And now, they tell me he is
70, which is hard to believe.
But one thing has
remained unchanged.
He always gave us terribly
exciting ideas, insights,
and he still is at this today.
So I wish, Phil, that you
will remain in this situation
for many years to come.
Now, I have to warn you
all that this talk will
be very different
from Dr. Sagen's talk.
It is scientific, and it
will contain a number--
even a number of algebraic
formulae that's terrible.
[LAUGHTER]
I am going to talk
about the subject that--
[LAUGHTER]
--has been very active for the
last year, namely the subject
of neutrinos from the sun.
For many years, this
has been a great puzzle.
And to talk about
that, let me start
by telling you the nuclear
reactions which are supposed
to go on in the sun.
They are listed here.
And many of them
could use neutrinos.
The fundamental the
action, of course, is the--
this doesn't seem to work--
the fundamental
reaction is the top one,
which is the current of two
protons giving a deuteron,
a positron, and a neutrino.
And then, most of the deuterons
which are formed in this way
finally go to this
reaction, making Helium 4.
That gives the big energy.
But occasionally,
they make Bavarium 7.
which that happens
maybe one time in 1,000.
And Bavarium 7, then,
emits another neutrino.
And then again, in
a very rare event,
Bavarium 7 will
capture another proton
and give a very odd
nucleus, Boron 8,
which produces neutrinos of
tremendous energy, 14MAB.
Here, I have given the energies.
C means continuous spectrum.
And this is the maximum energy
of the continuous spectrum.
In two reactions, you get
a definite energy neutrino.
Well, the question is, can
you observe the neutrinos?
It is very difficult to observe
neutrinos of about one MAB.
That is well known.
And it is also
well known that it
gets a little easier if the
neutrinos have higher energy.
In this connection, then,
Willie Fowler and John Bacon
had a very good idea.
They said, well, we
might use Chlorine 37.
There is a state
in Argon 37, which
is very similar to
the Chlorine 37 state.
It's a so-called analog state.
And therefore, the
transition, the capture,
of a neutrino by Chlorine
37, giving these analog
states in 37, which is
highly excited by six
million electron watts--
this is a super-allowed
transition,
that is, the transition
is as easy as any neutrino
capture can ever be.
And so they decided,
let's take Chlorine 37
and observe the Argon
37 which is formed.
Ray Davis of Brookhaven, now of
the University of Pennsylvania,
has now tried to observe the
capture of solar neutrinos
for nearly 20 years.
He uses a [? tanker ?]
of carbon tetrachloride.
He flushes the argon
out by helium and argon,
puts the argon into
a Geiger counter,
and uses the decay of
Argon 37 which takes place
by capture of an atomic
electron in the [? cache, ?]
giving Chlorine
37 and a neutrino.
Of course, you can't observe
that neutrino, either.
But you can observe
that the resulting
atom is missing a K electron.
Thereupon, it emits
X-rays of a few kilobytes.
And those you can observe.
This is the principle
of the observation.
But-- and indeed, Davis
did observe neutrinos,
but only about a third
of the predicted number.
This is summarized in
an article by Davis
and two collaborators
going back to 1981.
Well, so what's wrong?
The main person who
investigated this problem
has been John Bacon of the
Institute of Advanced Studies.
And He has tried almost
anything in the theory
of either nuclear reactions
or the constitution of the sun
to try and clear up this
puzzle, to no avail.
It just doesn't remove
the discrepancy.
The way they go about it is
that maybe the temperature
in the center of the
sun is lower than
has been generally supposed.
And for that purpose,
they need information
about the opacity
of solar material
and the different conditions,
density, and temperature.
There is a lot of
contributions by people
at Los Alamos and Livermore.
But the result
remained the same.
There is a discrepancy by
a factor of 3, or maybe 4.
At the same time, Willie
Fowler and his group,
experimenters group, at Cal Tech
have re-examined the nuclear
reactions, and have found that
the cross-section measurements
for the reaction leading to
Bavarium 7 or to Boron 8,
that these measurements
were correct,
in spite of some people
from other laboratories--
go ahead-- doubted that.
Well, the whole problem was
re-examined very carefully
in 1982 by Bahcall and others
in a very beautiful paper
in the views of modern
physics, in which they discuss,
in particular,
[? probable ?] errors
of each step of the argument.
Of course, one point in
the argument everybody
believes, namely that the
proton-proton reaction
makes the energy in the sun.
Not only is it the
logical thing to assume,
but in addition, the general
idea of thermonuclear reactions
in stars has led to a very
detailed understanding
of the further
evolution of stars,
and in particular,
all the details
of the red giant
formation and evolution.
I especially asked
Bahcall the other day
in a long telephone
conversation,
how sure is he of his results?
And he said, well, we have
gone through all the steps.
We have even results with
three times the standard error.
I don't believe there is any
way to escape the conclusion.
Well, one way was once
proposed by Willie Fowler.
He called it the
Desperate Theory.
Everybody knows that the
light comes out of the sun
only after some 5
or 10 million years.
So what we see today is
energy which was produced
maybe 10 million years ago.
So maybe the sun was hotter
in those days, more luminous
than it is today, which would
be a rather sad conclusion
because it would predict that
we would go into a severe ice
age in a few million years.
That's less threatening
than nuclear winter,
but still not very promising.
Bahcall and others
made a modified theory
whose results are given here.
But in the meantime,
they have gone back
to the theory of 1982.
The theory after all
corrections predicts
that you should observe
on Earth about 6 SNU.
That's a funny unit.
Admit It only-- and
I won't explain it.
It tells you how many counts
Mr. Davis ought to observe.
But this experiment
gives only 2 SNU.
Now, it is somewhat
frustrating to rely
on that funny nucleus, Boron 8.
It would be much nicer
to observe directly
the neutrinos which come from
the combination of two photons
because we know exactly
how often that must happen,
because that gives
us the energy which
the sun emits every second,
the so-called solar constant.
Well, to avoid the [? lions ?]
on the rare side chain,
it was proposed many years ago
to use a different detector,
namely Gallium 71.
And the only thing that's
wrong with that proposal
is that gallium is a very
rare element, and therefore
terribly expensive.
But it obviously was
an important experiment
to do, to find out the
solution to this puzzle.
Well, the National Science
Foundation unfortunately
rejected the proposal
several times
to carry out this experiment.
The Europeans are somewhat
more open to suggestions,
so this experiment
is going to be
done by a collaboration of
Italian, French, and German
physicists, which
will be carried out
in Gran Sasso in Italy,
and is being started now.
This gallium experiment
measures directly
the neutrinos which are made
in the proton-proton reaction.
And I have written down
here the capture rates
in these funny units,
SNU, for three detectors.
Don't pay any attention
to the lithium.
The chlorine which has been used
observes practically nothing
from the proton-proton reaction.
And the observation comes mostly
from Bavarium 7 and Boron 8.
By contrast, gallium
would observe mostly
proton-proton neutrinos,
some, Bavarium 7,
and very few, Boron 8.
It also would give
a lot more SNU.
In gallium, the neutrino
capture leads to germanium.
And germanium being an analog
of carbon in the Periodic Table,
lends itself to a very
ingenious detection
scheme proposed by Davis.
He's a good chemist.
You make germanium.
So the problem remains, why
are there only one third
as many neutrinos as
there ought to be?
It was suggested fairly
early that maybe neutrinos
transform into each other.
Namely, we know there are
different kinds of neutrinos,
electron neutrinos, and muon
neutrinos, and tau neutrinos.
And it was suggested that
maybe these neutrinos are not
the ones which
propagate in free space.
And that's a very standard
occurrence in particle physics.
You know about it probably
in the case of K mesons.
And there are many
other examples.
The particles which interact
with other particles
are usually not the
same as the particles
which propagate in free space.
So then, you assume that
free neutrinos are not
equal to these.
And if that is
so, then neutrinos
which I should call Neu-1
and Neu-2 will propagate.
And that will have the
consequence that in free space,
neutrinos oscillate between
electron neutrinos and mu
neutrinos.
[? Linus ?] claimed
at one time that he
had observed such
oscillations using
the neutrinos from the
Savannah River Reactor.
But later experiments did
not confirm his results.
In fact, experiments
recently done at CERN
find a certain result which
involves two quantities,
namely the difference in
mass of these neutrinos
and the angle of coupling.
I go into that a
little more later.
Namely, the electron neutrino
is not quite the neutrino Neu-1,
but they are off by a
certain angle, theta.
And the CERN experiments
show that the square
of the mass difference times
square of twice that angle
must be less than 0.03
electron watts square.
This is the dimension
because of the mass.
The direct experiments on the
mass of the electron neutrino
show probably by now that this
mass is less than 10 electron
watts, very far
from this number.
Now, if oscillations
were to exist,
then the electron
neutrinos from the sun
might be converted into
either mu or tau neutrinos
on their way to the Earth.
For this, you need a mass
difference greater than 10
to minus 13.
But you would need desperately
that the coupling angle would
be very large, namely that the
free neutrinos are maximally
different from the
neutrinos interacting
with electrons or mus.
That is very unlikely.
But it can-- a priori, it
cannot be ruled out completely.
So this was the
situation until recently.
And recently, two Russian
scientists [? Michraiv ?]
and [? Smirnov ?] proposed
a theory which I believe is
the correct theory.
And they use the
mixing of neutrinos,
but in a much more
intelligent original way.
Then I'll discuss
in the last slide.
I assume only two
neutrino types, electron
and mu neutrinos.
And in vacuum, they are coupled.
In terms of the free
neutrinos, Neu-1 and Neu-2,
N-1 commonly [? writes ?] that
the electron neutrino is cross
of a certain coupling [? and ?]
with theta times the free
neutrino Neu-1 plus
sine theta, times Neu-2.
And the mu neutrino, of
course, is orthogonal to that.
Then if the free neutrinos
have masses, M2 and M1,
you can write the mass
matrix in this form.
There is a diagonal
term which is
of no relevance, plus
another term which
contains the difference
of the two masses,
and times this very simple
matrix, which is non diagonal.
In terms, the
[? first term ?] refers
to electron neutrinos, the
second one to mu neutrinos.
Now so far, it is no
different from the last slide.
But now, they make
use of a theory which
was developed by
Wolfenstein of Carnegie Tech
and published in
Physics Review in 1978.
And he says as follows.
Neutrinos-- when
neutrinos are in matter,
then all neutrinos
interact with matter
by means of the
neutral weak current.
But that's of no
interest because it's
the same for all neutrinos.
It doesn't help convert
one into the other.
However, the electrons also
will interact with the electron
neutrinos, and none other,
by the charge weak current
in which an electron
is absorbed by a proton
and becomes a neutrino
plus a neutron.
And this has the consequence
that there is effectively,
in matter, a potential
energy for neutrinos which
is the universal
Faraday constant,
g multiplied by the electron
density, a number of electrons,
for aggregate volume.
So far, the
Wolfenstein theory, it
says then that the relation
between momentum and energy
of a neutrino goes like this.
The momentum square
plus mass square
is not equal to E square,
the energy square,
but energy minus the
potential energy squared.
And this potential energy,
which only exists for electron
neutrinos--
I expand this-- is equivalent
to having an extra mass
for electron neutrinos,
which is equal to 2E,
twice the neutrino energy,
times that potential energy.
And so now, my mass matrix gets
added to it, an interaction
term, which is this 2EV.
And that can be
written in this way.
It's proportional to the
density of the matter,
and to the energy
of the neutrino.
And I call that A.
Now, I add this to
the mass matrix.
And this will add to
just to the electron
part of the mass matrix,
electron neutrino part.
It will add a term here.
And I wrote it in
such a way that I
added one half A here and minus
one half A for the mu neutrino.
And delta here is the
difference in mass,
the mass of the, essentially,
mu neutrino minus the mass
of the electron neutrino.
And remember, you always have
to use the square of the masses.
Now, therefore,
obviously, when you
would look at this
equation, you see
that the difference in
masses becomes smallest
when the A, which is
proportional to the density,
is equal to delta
times cosine 2 theta.
And then, you have a minimum
in the difference of the two
masses.
And I will show you a
curve of what that--
of the consequence of that.
Namely, there are
two possible values
for the mass square
of a neutrino.
If you have no
density of electrons,
then you have the
electron neutrino here
at the low mass, no
neutrino at a higher mass.
But when you get to the
point where this condition is
satisfied, that A is equal to
the difference of mass square,
that's this point,
then at this point--
you can probably not
see that faint line--
at this point, the
electron neutrino
would get a bigger mass
than the mu neutrino.
But there is the
non-diagonal term
in the matrix, which means that,
actually, the curves do not
cross.
But this curve which starts
as the electron neutrino
ends up at high electron
density as the mu neutrino,
and vise versa.
And so, this means, then,
a very interesting thing.
And that's now the
theory of [? Michraiv ?]
and [? Smirnov. ?]
If you start--
well, let me first say that
for our given neutrino energy,
there is a certain density at
which the two curves cross.
And that density is determined
by the difference in mass
of mu neutrino and
electron neutrino,
and by the universal
[? Faraday ?] constant,
which we know very well.
So at present, the difference of
the masses of the two neutrinos
is not known.
But it surely is a
constant of nature.
And therefore, this lambda
is a certain number,
which we don't know.
But it's a number.
And now, let's
assume that neutrinos
are produced at a
certain density, one
near the center of the sun.
Then as they travel
out through the sun,
they will go through
this resonance
if their energy is
greater than the energy--
than a certain
critical energy which
is equal to that lambda
divided by the density
at the center of the sun.
If, however, the-- so
if this is the case,
then they were automatically
run down the green curve,
starting out as electron
neutrinos running down
the green curve.
They become mu neutrinos.
And they change thereby
into mu neutrinos.
And that means they
become unobservable
because mu neutrinos can
only be changed into--
in matter, they
could only be changed
into mu mesons, which
have a mass of 100
million electron watts.
And no neutrino, which
is produced in the sun,
has anything like that energy.
So those neutrinos,
therefore, which
are created at a density
above the crossing point,
go down the green curve and end
up as unobservable mu neutrinos
once they leave the
sun and come to Earth.
And that would
explain how it comes
that the neutrinos from the sun
are not observable on Earth.
That clearly is going too far,
because after all, Mr. Davis
did observe some neutrinos--
not enough, but some.
And this is an important point.
So conversely, if the
neutrino is made--
has a lesser energy
than the density
at the center of the sun,
it would be somewhere
on this curve.
Remember, what matters is
the product of the density
times the electron--
times the energy
of the neutrino.
So neutrinos of lesser energy
than might be produced here.
And [? SU ?] would
use the density
as the neutrino
goes out of the sun.
It goes down the periphery
curve and ends up
as an electron neutrino.
So the simplest conclusion,
which you may draw,
is the high energy neutrinos
will be created here
and will be unobservable.
The lower energy neutrinos
will be created here,
and will remain
electron neutrinos,
and remain,
therefore, observable.
That is the theory
of [? Michraiv ?]
and [? Smirnov. ?] Some are
translated into different
languages, quite apart from
being translated from Russian
into English.
And so, let's see
what we can conclude.
For that, I go to the paper
which I mentioned before,
which says that from
Boron 8, you get 4 SNU.
From all other nuclei,
you get 1 and 1/2.
Davis has observed 2.1.
And so, I say, these neutrinos
are low energy neutrinos,
and therefore are green--
no, are purple-- and are
therefore observable.
And also, a few of
the Boron 8 neutrinos
must be observable, maybe 0.5,
plus or minus 0.5, not clear,
whether any of them
need to be observable.
I evaluated this wrongly.
Fowler then corrected
me in a letter.
And the result is
that the Boron 8
neutrinos are observable if
they have less than 8MAB.
And that leads to a difference
in mass square between the two
types of neutrinos of 10 to the
minus 4 electron watts square.
It means, by the way,
very importantly,
this works only if the mu
neutrino has a higher mass
than the electron neutrino.
And so, if we assume tentatively
the electron neutrino
has no mass, then
the mu neutrino
would have a mass of one
hundredth of an electron watt,
totally unobservable
by other means.
Now, that's not
the only condition.
You also need to have--
as the neutrinos
go out of the sun,
you have to have an
adiabatic transition.
Well, that gives a
certain condition.
And I will not bother
you with the details.
It tells you that
the coupling angle--
you'll remember,
electron neutrinos
are cosine theta times Neu-1
plus sine theta, times Neu-2.
But this coupling angle must be
greater than 0.01 radian, which
is 0.6 degrees.
It's almost certain if there
is a coupling angle at all
that it will be greater
than this number.
For instance, those of you who
would know particle physics
will remember that the Cabibbo
angle is about 13 degrees,
much, much larger
than 0.6 degrees.
So it is essentially certain
that the angle is big enough.
However, it says one very
important thing, namely
that both neutrinos
must have mass.
And that is not at all obvious.
When we started talking about
neutrinos back 50 years ago,
we thought, I think,
practically all of us,
of neutrinos without any mass.
And they have great
attraction, aesthetically.
But I have no
preconceived notions,
so I am perfectly satisfied.
If neutrinos have some mass,
it will be very, very small.
So if all this
theory is correct,
then it says that we don't
observe those Boron 8
neutrinos.
And only the Boron
8 neutrinos are
converted into mu neutrinos.
And if you remember the table
I showed you at one time,
if you use a gallium detector,
then you do not preferentially
observe Boron 8 neutrinos,
but instead, you
observe all neutrinos,
and particularly
those coming directly from
the proton-proton reaction.
So with a gallium
detector, you should
observe essentially the same
as the theorists have always
predicted.
You should get the theoretical
result, which is about 110 SNU.
So we have to hope
for the Europeans
to get experiments with
the gallium detector.
Well, I have shown you
the qualitative analytic
discussion, which I have made.
But there are people who are
much more industrious than I,
and know how to use a
computer, which I don't.
And they found, then, not only
one solution of the problem,
but two.
And the first
people who did that
were the Russians themselves.
And then with somewhat
improved technique,
it was done by Rosen
and Gelb at Los Alamos,
and got these results.
Now, if you believe
that Davis observes
one third of the
expected neutrinos,
you should use the diamonds.
The more recent ideas
of Bahcall are that he
observed only a quarter.
And then, you should
look at the [? circus. ?]
And so what is plotted
here is delta m square
in electron watts square, and 10
to the minus 4 is my solution.
Constant mass, arbitrary
coupling angle, theta.
But there is a second
solution, which
is shown here with much
smaller mass difference.
You would have thought 10 to
the minus 4 is small enough,
but they get even less, but
with a definite relation
between the mass difference
and the coupling angle.
And in fact, the relation is
that the product of these two
is a certain number.
It is delta m squared times sine
square of the coupling angle,
is 4 times 10 to the
minus 8 electron watts
square, small enough.
They have confirmed
the solution which I've
published in addition to this.
Now, if delta m squared is
less than my 10 to the minus 4,
then also, neutrinos other
than the Boron neutrinos will
be converted into mu neutrinos.
But we know that we must have
some neutrinos left over,
because after all, Davis
did observe one third or one
quarter of the expected number.
So there must be
some other condition
which prevents the conversion
of the electron neutrinos
into mu neutrinos.
And that's the condition that
the transition be adiabatic.
This was pointed out
not by Rosen and Gelb,
but by Haxton of the
University of Washington.
And he has shown that the
Rosen-Gelb solution essentially
corresponds to the
adiabatic condition, which
I mentioned before.
And assuming that Haxton
finds analytically
that this product should
be 6, 10 to the minus 8,
close enough to the
4 10 to the minus 8
that Rosen and Gelb had found.
Now, because the low energy
neutrinos are now lost,
the gallium experiment, which
measures mostly low energy
neutrinos, will now
also give a response
less than the original theory,
if the second solution is
correct.
I'll show you here a rather
nice curve of Rosen and Gelb,
which tells you the
probability of reaching Earth
as a function of
the energy in MAB.
And there is the stars,
which is my solution.
You have practically no
probability for the high energy
neutrino, but all the
low energy neutrinos
will remain electron
neutrinos and be observable.
And contrary-wise, from
the Rosen-Gelb solution,
it's the other way around.
So the gallium
experiment therefore
has become even more important.
It will make it possible to
distinguish the two solutions.
A question was raised,
is there any upper limit
to sine square theta?
This was investigated
by Suckley group,
who found, yes, there is.
The upper limit is
something like a half--
well, two thirds, actually--
essentially independent
of the mass. difference.
The best calculation so far
has been made by two people
at [? Feremy ?] Lab,
Park and Walker, who plot
here some beautiful curves.
It all uses the same
general idea, namely
conversion of neutrinos
from electron neutrinos
to mu neutrinos in the
sun due to high density
of the matter in the sun.
Plotted here is,
again, the difference
in mass between the
two types of neutrinos.
Plotted here is essentially
the sine square of 2 theta.
And the contour lines correspond
to various possible results
of the Davis experiment.
What he gives is 2.1 SNU.
That's this curve.
But he says plus or minus 0.3.
That's three times
more than error.
So it can be anything
between 1.8 and 2.4.
All right.
If you follow the
2.1 curve, there's
first a horizontal
[? sledge, ?] which
is my attempt at a
minus 4 mass difference.
Then there is the slant
line, which is essentially
the Rosen-Gelb solution.
It has a wiggle because
different types of neutrinos
undergo the non-adiabatic
transition, which
goes to smaller mass difference
and higher sine square theta.
And finally, there
is the vertical line,
which is essentially the Suckley
limit at high coupling angle.
So this tells you, then, you
have essentially two solutions
to the problem.
Either the mass difference
is 10 to the minus 4,
and then the coupling angle
can be anything, or else,
the mass difference is much
less than 10 to the minus 4,
and then the coupling angle
must be directly related
to the mass difference.
Well, the [? Feremy ?] Lab
people, Park and Walker,
they went on and
discussed what should
be the result of the gallium
experiment, once it is done.
And that now is
particularly interesting.
This, again, is mass
difference, angle,
and the dotted lines are
the two limits of the Davis
experiment with chlorine.
The solid lines are the
contour lines for the gallium
experiment to be done.
And so, you see, if
the solution is along
this line, or along
this line, then
the gallium experiment
should give, oh,
somewhere between 100-120 SNU.
But if the solution is the type
preferred by Rosen and Gelb,
then the gallium experiment
will give you a greatly reduced
count, maybe as low as 10 SNU,
10 percent of the theoretically
predicted number.
So this is extremely
interesting, and makes,
of course, the
gallium experiment
more and more important.
And so what can we conclude?
If the gallium experiment
gives the high value,
about 100 SNU, then there
are two alternatives.
Either my original
interpretation of the two--
of the Russian suggestion
is the right one,
the mass difference
is 10 to the minus 4
and the angle is
undetermined, or there
is some totally unknown
other explanation.
Now, Bahcall swears
that his theory
of the temperature distribution
of the sun is correct.
So it's very unlikely that
there is another explanation.
However, one would have to
say, if gallium gives 100 SNU
or so, then the
[? Michraiv-Smirnov ?]
explanation is merely likely.
It is not absolutely proved.
But if the gallium experiment
gives a much lower number--
let us say, something less than
60, perhaps as low as 10 SNU--
then that can only be explained
by the Russian suggestion,
because there is nothing that
we can do about the distribution
of temperature in the sun,
which would reduce the number
of quote, unquote,
[? "unreactions," ?]
because those reactions
give us our light.
We know exactly how much
energy the sun emits.
And so, we know exactly how
many proton-proton correlations
occur.
And therefore, no change of the
solar temperature distribution
could explain the gallium
result anywhere in that region.
In that case, then, the
Michraiv-Smirnov answer theory
is definitely proved.
And we must then assume
that, indeed, neutrinos
have a mass, that the
mass of the mu neutrino
is greater than that of
the electron neutrino.
And how much it is can
be determined, then,
from the gallium experiment.
If the gallium experiment
gives the high value,
then one probably
has to do still
another experiment showing
that it is, indeed,
the Russian suggestion
and not something
funny about the sun
that gives the--
that is the cause
of the Davis result.
If gallium is as
low as about 10 SNU,
then delta m square is of
order 10 to the minus 6,
and sine square of 2-theta
is of the order of 0.1.
And that's very
close to the Cabibbo
angle, which would be 0.16.
There is no good reason why
it should be just the Cabibbo
angle.
Now, the most exciting part of
this whole story [INAUDIBLE]
is that it might permit
us a glimpse into the gut.
And by this, I don't
mean the intestines.
But I mean the
grand unified theory
that particle
theorists are fond of,
and of which I
understand nothing.
[LAUGHTER]
However, all particle
theorists tell me
that in gut, there
should be right handed
neutrinos in addition
to the ones we know,
which are left handed neutrinos.
And these right handed
neutrinos should
have a mass about equal
to the grand unification
mass, which is 10 to the
14 GEV, or 10 to the 23 EV.
So we are talking
at the same time
about terribly small masses
and terribly big masses.
There is a particular theory
by Gell-Mann and two others,
simultaneously
obtained by Yanagida,
'78 and '79, according to
which, the mass of neutrinos
of a given [? flavor ?] [? I ?]
should be the mass squared
of the corresponding quark
divided by some constant
and the mass of the
grand unification theory.
Of course, that
mass nobody knows.
But it is about that number.
Why the K appears there,
I haven't any idea.
[LAUGHTER]
The Michraivs
neutrino would have 10
to the minus 6 EV, and the tau
neutrino 10 to the minus 3 EV,
with the right handed
neutrinos having
a mass like the gut mass.
It is obvious that the mu
neutrino would then not
be enough to satisfy any
solution of the solar neutrino
puzzle.
Only the tau neutrino would.
The difference of the square of
the tau neutrino and E neutrino
mass would be 10
to the minus 6 EV
square, which falls
right into the range
of the Rosen-Gelb solution.
And it falls right
at the place where
gallium would give the minimum
response of about 10 SNU.
So we must then assume
that, in the sun,
the electron neutrino converts
into a tau neutrino, not
a mu neutrino.
At present, I don't
know any experiment
which would distinguish
between tau and mu neutrino
as the product.
But you can see
that it will be most
exciting to have the result
of the gallium experiment.
This can, first of all,
show whether or not
the [? Michraiv-Smirnov ?]
suggestion is correct,
and whether this is the solution
of the solar neutrino puzzle.
And secondly, it may
give us an insight
into grand unified
theory, and insight
into things which occur at
energies of 10 to the 14 GEV,
energies which surely are
beyond the most ambitious plans
of accelerators, and surely--
and which also are beyond the
range of cosmic ray neutrinos.
They go up to about 10 to the 20
EV, whereas the gut is about 10
to the 23 EV.
So there is a good
chance, I believe,
that the neutrinos will give
us a look into energies so high
that we have no reasonable
expectation of reaching them
by accelerators or
other observations.
And if that is so, then
it was most fortunate
that Ray Davis did not
observe the neutrinos that
were expected, but observed
only a small fraction of them.
And no matter how much
the theorists pressed him,
he still stuck to
his small number.
And this may have shown us
a very interesting feature
of neutrino physics, and
possibly, the best [? hand ?]
at knowing something about the
very highest energy particle
physics.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]